-Thank you
for coming back to the show.
-Thank you. I feel like
this is my second home now.
It's awesome.
-Right. It should be.
We love having you on.
'Cause I love...
-Yes.
-I mean, last time you were
here, we had...
-Yeah.
-...Kevin Hart was here.
-[ Laughing ] We did.
That was a lot of fun.
-And I asked him to stay out
and play with the animals.
-Yeah.
-And he said, "I hate animals."
[ Laughter ]
Or, oh, no -- actually, he goes,
"I like animals.
I'm afraid of them."
-All right. That's okay.
That's all right.
-And he had -- oh, my gosh.
It was the funniest.
-Yeah. I like to think
maybe we helped him,
a little bit, overcome his fear.
-Maybe.
-A bit more comfortable.
But, I mean, for me,
it was really cool
because we actually reached over
100 million people on Facebook,
so for me, what a great...
-Yeah.
It was the number-one
trend on YouTube.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, thank you so much.
-100 million people.
-Yeah, it was awesome.
And for me,
that's just such a great way
to get the -- the message
of wildlife and conservation
out to so many people,
so thank you so much.
It was awesome.
-No, are you kidding me?
Thank you right back to you.
-You, as well. Thanks, guys.
[ Chuckles ]
-The show -- "Crikey!"
-Yes.
-"Crikey! It's the Irwins."
-You've got to say,
"Crikey! It's the Irwins."
-Oh, sorry. [Australian accent]
-"Crikey! It's the Irwins."
-There you go.
-[ Normal voice ] Yeah.
-Perfect.
-It -- It --
It was the biggest debut
for Animal Planet
in the last five years,
so congratulations on that.
-Thank you so much.
Thanks, guys.
-Over 12 million people
have seen it around the world.
It's a giant hit.
-Yeah.
-I'm happy for you
and your whole family.
You know I love the whole fam.
So, thank you for coming back.
-Thank you.
-Now, you brought
some animals tonight,
and, hopefully, I'll get along
with them and...
-Yes. Hopefully.
-And, yeah. Yeah.
-It's gonna be really fun.
So, are you ready
for the first animal?
-Yeah, here we go.
Absolutely, we love it.
-Okay, we've got two of them
coming up here.
-Okay.
-So, this is Ping and Pong,
and they are
absolutely adorable.
Hey, guys!
Hello! Hello, guys!
[ Otters squeaking ]
-Take your body and kind of...
-Yeah, you can hold them
really nice and tight in there.
These are otters.
These are actually
little, baby otters.
That's great.
[ Otters squeaking ]
So, see those...
-Oh, my gosh.
-...those little vocalizations
that they're making?
-Yes.
-Now, that's actually --
Oh, he's eating you
a little bit.
-All right, watch it.
Ohh.
-That's how they communicate
with one another.
Now,
Asian small-clawed otters --
these are the smallest otters
in the entire world.
Whoops.
-He's eating...
-He's eating --
He's eating you now.
-...the microphone, yeah.
-Now, these guys
are really cool.
They're from Asia.
They're amazing.
And they've actually got --
I think he loves me.
-I think it's cute,
but you never know.
The -- The squeaks.
-They're still babies.
-Yeah.
-So they will get
a lot bigger than this.
All right, here we go.
[ Laughter ]
-They'll get bigger, yes. Okay.
-They will. They will.
-Oh, my goodness.
-Aren't they just so special?
-Yep. Okay.
-Here.
Let me put your mic back --
mic back on.
-Hi. Yeah.
-There we go.
-Hi, buddy. Okay, it's good.
-Isn't that awesome?
So, they can actually have...
[ Otter squeaking ]
-He found it again.
-They can have...
-He's gonna find it again.
-Oh, my goodness.
-Hi, buddy Ping, buddy Pong.
-Ping and Pong.
-Hi, buddy.
-Now, they actually have
the finest fur in the world.
Oh, he's giving you a kiss.
-I think he almost bit --
or bit me.
He almost bit me or kissed me.
-Oh, they're so -- so cute.
-Hey, buddy. I love them.
-Congratulations.
Well done. Well done.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm not squeezing him
or anything, I swear.
-Thanks, Ping and Pong.
-I'm just holding him,
and that's all.
All right, I'm ready
to get Ping and Pong...
-All right, we're good? Okay.
-Thank you for this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you very much.
-Oh, my God.
-Oh, my God. Thank you.
-Thank you very much.
-Ohh, gosh.
-How cute are they?
Are you -- Are you all good?
-Yeah, I'm great.
I love --
Yeah, that's fantastic.
-That's good.
Okay.
So, next, for this next one,
I think we're gonna
come around again.
We're gonna sit down here.
And I'm gonna grab a few pieces
here for you of sweet potato.
-Mm-hmm. Oh, man.
-This next animal
loves sweet potatoes,
so if you want to sit down...
-Oh, okay. Okay. Oh, no.
-...and then, you can put...
[ Laughter ]
-I can see
what's kind of coming.
-You can put your legs
out like this.
-Oh, gosh.
-Now, you want to hold
the sweet potato just here,
so they don't bite your fingers.
-Oh, no.
What do you mean
they won't bite my fingers --
hold it like this?
-So, it'll -- it'll be good.
-I don't know.
-It'll be good, I promise.
-What do I do with that?
-You can grab that one, as well,
and you can feed them.
-Oh, no.
-They love sweet potato.
-All right.
-All right, so, we've got
Quill Smith and Quilly Nelson.
And you'll see their names
in a second.
Come on in, guys.
These are porcupine.
-All righty.
[ Laughter ]
Good to see you.
-Hello.
-Okay. What do I...
-There you go.
-Now, can I...
-Have a go at that.
So, now, these guys --
they're African --
[ Laughter ]
He's curling up now.
These are
African crested porcupines,
the largest rodent
in the continent of Africa.
-Okay, this might be the most
dangerous thing I've ever done.
-And see those spines there?
Yeah.
That's actually --
That's their defense mechanism.
If a predator is gonna get them,
they'll actually sink them
right down into their skin.
And that's -- that's how
they avoid predators.
They're amazing.
-All right, all right.
-How cool is that?
-Does he want --
Yeah, it's unbelievable.
-And see how they're --
That shaking there means
they're a little bit --
a little bit unhappy.
They're thinking,
"Just what's going on?"
[ Laughter ]
But, see,
once they've got that --
once they got the sweet potato,
they're completely happy.
They absolutely love it.
-I can feel him eating it,
but I just...
-That's great. How cool is that?
-Yeah, man.
-Look at them go.
-Well, I'm just happy
that I had kids,
you know...
-So cool. Here you go.
-...when I -- when I...
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
What do you think, eh?
-...when I could.
-Now, they'll get...
[ Laughter ]
...they'll get
a lot bigger, too.
When they're full-grown,
they could easily have a go
at a lion.
If -- If --
If it's getting close,
they'll just stab right in
with those quills.
[ Laughter ]
How cool is that?
-All right,
this is unbelievable.
-They're amazing, aren't they?
-It is a pleasure
to meet you guys.
Oh, wow! My God!
All right, all right, Robert.
-You're good. You're good.
All right, should we
take them right now?
-Robert. Robert. Robert.
-You're good. You're good.
-Robert.
-All right, bye, guys.
-Now...
-Be very careful,
whatever happens next.
-I don't know
how we're gonna get this.
Here. Let's see.
-Okay.
-There we go.
You're good now.
-All right, all right.
This is great.
-All right.
See you later, guys.
[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my heavens.
All righty. Okay.
-Are you good?
-That's --
That's not the carrot.
All right, here you go.
[ Laughter ]
You're having --
the carrot's over here.
Here you go, buddy.
Eat this.
-[ Chuckling ] Okay.
-All right,
good to see these guys.
Oh, my gosh.
Yeah, I think --
[ Laughter ]
-Wow, they really love it here.
-Security? Oh, no. Okay.
-[ Laughing ] Okay.
All right, no worries.
There we go.
-All right, yep.
Okay, good.
-It's a bit of a challenge
picking them up, as you can see.
-Ohh. Ohh, my gosh.
-There we go.
-Yeah.
-Well done, guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Good job.
That was great.
That was so cool.
Do you want me to grab
your sweet potato for you?
-Yeah, that's what he was,
yeah, going for.
-All right. No worries.
So, I think we're gonna stay
down here for a little while.
[ Laughter ]
Have a look at this guy.
Now, this is...
-I'm not putting him in my lap.
I'm not.
-This is a giant aardvark.
-I don't want to move.
-And the aardvarks --
they are native to Africa,
as well.
See those massive claws there?
That's what they use to dig.
So, they're really
interesting animals.
They've got that big, long nose.
-Yeah.
-And that's how they smell.
They've got a great sense
of smell.
And the end of their nose
actually looks a bit
like a marshmallow.
It's so cool.
-Has he -- Have we...
-How special are they?
-A random aardvark.
-Big ears, great hearing.
-This is -- And, sorry.
I didn't even quite even hear
what you were saying.
-Yes.
-Is he an -- It's an aardvark --
It's an anteater?
-Yeah, so they'll --
they'll eat ants and termites.
And, yeah,
they're great at digging.
They'll find a termite mound.
They'll break into it.
But we've got
a little mixture here,
and that's kind of a mix
of squished insects and bugs,
and they absolutely love it.
See that?
-Absolutely.
[ Laughter ]
-It's really good.
So, it's actually
really quite good for them.
They absolutely love this.
-I can't believe it.
-So, we're gonna head down here
now for this one.
We couldn't really fit this one
on the stage.
-Okay.
-So, this --
This is Debra --
This is Debra the Zebra.
-Oh, my goodness.
-And I absolutely love Debra.
Do you want me
to come around this side?
-Sure.
-So...there we we go.
-Debra the Zebra.
Hi. How you doing?
-So, Debra the Zebra -- she's
actually still quite young.
-Hi.
-She's a young little zebra,
and she still loves her bottles.
Now, she's only
about six months old.
You're welcome to pat her,
though.
-Six months old?
-She loves her pats, yeah.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Now, these guys --
they use those stripes
for camouflage.
They're one of the best
camouflage animals ever.
Now, do you want
to grab this bottle?
-Sure.
-And you can feed her.
Isn't that amazing?
She is so sweet.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Absolutely adorable,
aren't they?
-This looks fake almost.
-Yeah, yeah.
And unlike horses,
they can actually be
sometimes quite aggressive
out in the wild.
Yeah, really cool.
[ Laughter ]
So, that's Debra.
Isn't she cute?
-She's unbelievable.
And she's for sale
at FAO Schwarz for eight months.
[ Laughter ]
Just kidding.
-Oh, good girl, Debra.
-This is unbelievable.
-Yeah.
-Thank you for --
you kind of took it a little bit
easier on me this time.
I appreciate it.
-No worries. No worries.
-And Robert Irwin, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Crikey! It's the Irwins"
airs Sunday nights at 8:00 p.m.
on Animal Planet.